let me pull up this story from Reuters
here's here's the good news everybody
from Reuters EU aims to team up with
defense industry to speed up ammunition
output oh that's good news I mean I
personally don't mind it it's I'm having
a hard time finding gold.556 so are you
okay if you're upsets produce something
we can import you know the European
Union aims to join forces with the
blocks defense industry to speed up and
scale up the production of ammunition
badly needed in the battlefield in
Ukraine and to replenish military stocks
at home its Chief said on Saturday make
no mistake ladies and gentlemen this is
world war three will it escalate to the
point out will escalate to a conflict
outside of Ukraine is the question but
NATO and Russia are fighting and other
countries I believe are soon to be
involved China may start even zelenski's
warning about this China could team up
with Russia and then it's World War III
it's like oh okay if China does they're
not going to say that's the start of
World War III they're going to say the
Ukrainian invasion was the start of
World War III they're going to argue
that the Euro my Dan Pro test was the
start of World War III so we're in the
forest right now man I'll just say this
seeing a story this is like people were
showing around like crazy actually from
a week ago seeing a story where Europe
is going to start Mass producing bullets
I'm like yeah they're getting ready for
war we're going to see other
manufacturing too and we're going to see
the U.S shipping more more of the stuff
in so short-term good news if you invest
in like uh Lockheed or Northrop Grumman
you're Pro actually I'm going to check
that right now it's a it I mean this is
this is a an evergreen statement but
it's it's a good idea if you're a
Firearms owner to make sure that you
have you know a sufficient amount of
ammunition for each of your Firearms so
if you've got multiple firearms in
multiple different calibers you need to
get some ammunition for all of the
calibers
lockheed's up nine percent over last
year there you go it's a little bit
above you know average performing the
market too right right markets down you
know but nine percent all right what do
we got like Northrop
how are they doing is that publicly
traded oh yeah sure
there we go Northrop Grumman how are
they doing uh let's see in the past year
they're up four percent so big spike
they were actually they actually dropped
down quite a bit but uh you know it
really does seem like what's another
weapons manufacturer Boeing up four
percent they dropped down what happens
you see the spikes and the drops and I
think what happens is these well Boeing
uh 0.65 of the past year l310 I'm
getting four percent over the past year
that's where 240 per per share yeah you
know weird look look at L3 Technologies
down 43 over the past five years L3
what's L3 L3 they make a lot of laser
devices and smaller oh lasers they're
doing really well or what there's no
they're way down they're down 17 oh no
yeah you know we don't we don't need
lasers but you see the spikes in the
drops they'll sell off and then buy back
up and do these organized I mean it's
illegal to do that but I think that's
what happens is they sell off stock
plummets people panic sell and then they
buy a bunch back up unfortunate but
that's what happens when people control
the market my graphene investment's
doing real well
yeah man wow
I'm just waiting for the moment that
like these weapons manufacturers come
out and they're like we've made a
tremendous Discovery in weapons
technology the graphene bomb and then
it's just like the stock jumps making
better primer a couple nights ago and uh
just yeah graphene is going to be
utilize graphing bullets graphene
rifling all that stuff it's just
I'm not convinced but sure but think
about those corporations there's no war
okay we're out of the Middle East the
war nobody really believes in war and
Terror there's nothing really looming
what happens to those corporate I mean
these are made these are huge they're
still making products so they're a huge
military you've got so many people
invested in foreign war in the military
but there's nowhere to go so what do you
do you get a clown like zielinski and
you pump him up as some sort of Savior
and you let this you know
for years Putin obviously is a bad guy
but he's not the worst enemy that we
have and so you manufacture this and
then everybody you know I think they
thought they could conjure up the old
days of you know the beating the war
drums that would bring people together
and enrich the people who are getting
rich
zelenski is literally a clown
he was a comedian on a comedy show and
there's like viral clips of him playing
guitar naked on stage or like pretending
to be naked I was going apparently
pretty funny guy I never saw I don't
speak Ukraine yeah that's fine he's
probably a funny guy dancing and he was
uh he played a character on a TV show
about a comedian that became president
or something like that and then he
became president and it's just like and
deep down he wants to be loved All
actors do this obsession with being
liked which is why I think we could make
a hero out of him if he ends this war if
there's enough public support for it he
won't throw his life at it it works for
him as the puppet candidate because he
can speak you need someone who can stand
up and do the the propaganda shots and
everything that's for sure remember
those videos that came out that looked
like they were cgi'd it's like he would
like the trees weren't moving behind him
and then they're like no those are real
it's just the lighting is weird because
uh but they put spotlights on him it's
like yo the trees aren't moving either
people believe that stuff do you think
that if we were talking about Trump
earlier that if he ran again or I think
he's going to or I don't know Trump
already declared a while ago I haven't
heard from him in about a month and a
half uh or something like that so the
the media is just going to be like hey
Putin's friends trying to run for
president again
we can't let him we can't let Putin's
buddy get president or he'll give Russia
to all of Europe and and uh how can that
possibly be overcome the liberal
economic orders the Stranglehold on the
liberal on the Medias so like shows like
this you think share this show with your
friends if you think the liberal media
is bad he doesn't have a point
smooth it's going to be a rough sell on
people because they're gonna have to get
what 51 of the voting population to go
for this it's decentralization
um look man Don lemon's melting down
because his show is crumbling CNN's
losing whatever grip they had Zucker is
out the these these big networks they're
struggling to maintain the narrative
it's you know it's almost like we're
getting we talked about the time machine
what was it called the two different
species of humans one were like trolls
and one were like super smart or
whatever more locks
I forget the name something like that it
feels like that's what we're going
because right now you know to shout out
that podcast again which is just get
another fire Eclipse these women This
Woman's like
he asks are are you a feminist she's
like yeah I'm a feminist because like
the system is you know like this the
women should be
out and I'm just like holy holy crap
that that's a Biden voter right there
and then this everybody watching here is
a trump voter maybe some disados voters
because like there's a logical decision
to be made about the capabilities of
either man but there's no decision to be
made about Biden anybody who spends five
seconds reading is gonna be like this
man is not qualified to be president
period or I should say he should he just
be kept far away from Office his brain
don't work yeah but what we're getting
is these people who are just like I
don't know like I saw on the TV they
said Donald Trump was Russian and Russia
is like in Mexico and so we shouldn't I
don't want a Mexico president and then
you like have you seen these fleckers
talks things they do yeah I haven't seen
the flag of stocks but I I I know what
you're talking about they go down and
they'll ask a random person name name a
country that's name starts with the
letter U and they'll go uh Utah
and it's like I know dumb people exist
and you can find them and make videos
mocking them but I'm just growing
concerned that you know that let's talk
about the lab League thing real quick
back and then we'll get into it in a bit
it's just like Seamus coglin put it
really well Freedom Tunes guys shut up
he said Remember When a virus emerged in
right next a virus emerged in the city
that had a virus Factory and it merged
right next to the virus Factory but they
called you crazy for believing yeah that
it didn't come from the market a few
blocks away it's just like Jon Stewart
talked about that and he was just like
it's crazy they called him racist and
alt-right there are people that are so
dumb that zelenski can go on TV and I'm
driving down the street in West Virginia
and I see the Ukrainian Flags there
there's and West Virginia Virginia
Maryland there are people who they they
can't even point to Ukraine on a map and
they're like agreeing with a hundred
billion dollars in war funding for a
country they've never heard of
it's similar to voting against someone
which has been a big problem the last
five years is that people want to vote
against the guy they don't like not
right now they're fighting against
Russia it's not even for Ukraine I think
the Ukraine flag means we're afraid
Russia is going to take over Europe
they've just been scared to believe it
I don't know I guess the the goal with
the EU
is they want to make it just like the
United States they want it to be a large
centrally controlled block of different
economic regions right and so the more
they can induct other countries into it
Ukraine of course they they want Ukraine
in the EU the problem is their economy
is too bad so they're going to go with
NATO first Russia's like no way I'm not
letting you do this you're basically
taking over you know the funny thing
about Russia is there's a funny viral
video from a long time ago where this
woman is like
she's explaining that Russians are Asian
and they're like no they're not it's
like yes they are Russia is north of
China and like you can't and then
there's another video where like Indian
women are explaining that they're Asians
because India's in Asia and then people
like no you can't say that but I
remember I was talking to a friend and I
mentioned that Russia Russia Russians
were Russia was in Asia in fact most of
Russia is in Asia and then you have like
the Eastern portion what is it to West
of that mountain range to the Ural
Mountains the Euro mountains do you
think so yeah and um you know west of it
is Europe and then east of it but most
of Russia is in Asia and then I had to
explain to them I'm like Russia is like
50 miles from Japan and it's north of
China yeah people don't know how big
this place is they don't know what its
interests are all they know is
you know I don't know Communists from
the Soviet era or something I don't even
think that they they have a concept of
that I think that it's it's it's a far
more simplistic view of uh of Russia you
know it's the narrative is that Russia
is uh you know
is
among the basket of the of deplorables
essentially you know obviously Russia is
um an authoritarian Run state but it's
the the way that they've aligned Donald
Trump Russia and and essentially anyone
that has that has a dissenting opinion
in the United States is smeared with the
Russian
puppet uh narrative
um isn't zelenski getting rid of a bunch
of people though too many purged some of
his leaders defense ministers or Finance
ministers or
I mean he's doing his fair share I think
of crushing political discipline in his
own country yeah shut down media and
shut down television
I believe churches associated with
Russia yeah Russia North Dallas right so
yeah which I mean obviously that's
that's stuff that that the media in the
US doesn't want to talk about because
it's a liberal behavior and they want to
paint
um zielinski is a Democrat a democratic
uh government that that we can rely on
as a stable partner
um and they ignore the fact that Ukraine
was one of the most corrupt countries in
Europe uh Eastern Europe is terribly
corrupt they didn't handle the
transition from Soviet states to uh
liberal democracies uh the way that uh
the United States did
um it was significantly more corrupt and
and uh
Run for the oligarchs really that were
that whoever could grab power at the end
of the Soviet Union so the
the situation in the Ukraine is not you
know it's not the US's business thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time